you know as well as I but on the left
there's a belief about people like you
and me that and it's it's
psychologically very implausible but
this is what they believe that you and I
want to help the rich I got into
economics I stayed in it to help the
poor the advantage that our policies
have is that they actually help the poor
hi I'm Nicolas be with reason and today
we are sitting down with Deirdre
McCloskey she is an emeritus professor
of economics history English and
communication at the University of
Illinois at Chicago and the author most
recently of bushwa equality how ideas
not capital or institutions enrich the
world she's also a columnist for Reason
magazine Deirdre thanks so much for
talking with us a long time contributing
editor to Reason I'm extremely pleased
to be here well your latest column
because I think that puts us right into
a lot of current discussions is titled
the myth of technological unemployment
and a subhead is if the nightmare of
technological unemployment were true it
would have already happened repeatedly
and massively in it you take issue with
a lot of libertarian or free-market
economists who are talking about how you
know we've reached the end of
technological innovation or productivity
growth and yeah there's going to you
know we're going to have to find
something to do for people or replace by
robots
what's the wrong way I think it's just
completely wrong my friend Tyler Cohen
we at my friends at George Mason think
maybe it's time for an intervention in
Tyler and we think maybe we should send
him to to dry out somewhere because he
sees come on crazy on this and and he's
not alone I mean there are people like
Bob Gordon wrote a book last year which
was very successful at which argue which
argued that basically you know for say
goodbye to 2% even a percent
economically that we're innovation in
the United States is finished and we've
invented all the windows screens and
drop ceilings we're ever going to invent
and I I just they're they're whole bunch
of things wrong with it one is that it
doesn't
a lot of quantitative sense in Tyler's
book which is called averages over he's
got a chart which he says summarizes my
point it's terrible
see this falling share of labour and
national income you look closely at the
chart which is one of these Time
magazine charts and goes down like that
occurrence out it's gone from 63% to 61%
talking about to personally come on
Tyler please and then Bob likewise and
lots of others I mean it's it in fact
it's a very old theme people have been
saying since the beginning of modern any
kind of girls around 1800 that well it's
finished John Stuart Mill are great for
the great father of us all had that
opinion that the that the stationary
stayed as he called it was around the
corner and it hasn't happened yet that's
one thing Joe macare my friend it is
another optimist says look come on and
you need biological research and then
the the point that I like to make is
we're only talking about the United
States now wait a second time out the
world is growing income per head in real
terms is growing faster right now than
it ever has in the history of the world
these two countries China and India
forty percent of humankind are growing
like mad seven to ten percent breeze
although they are slowing down down
they're going from you and the seven
great if you like to have seven percent
girls in your salary so anyway there's
ample cause for optimism because when
those people come online you get masses
of engineers entrepreneurs free people
at least in India and we're hoping in in
China and they'll make inventions those
spillover to us just as our if we are
European North Western Europeans our
invention spilled over to them
so I it for the next I don't know
century or two I see no slowing down
let's talk about the the bushwa trilogy
yeah virtues equality of what not in
that you talked about the great and rich
I than you touched on it explain that
and talk about its causes and who are
the who are the people you're sparring
with I'm sparring with Marx I'm sparring
a Dean with Mel even I'm sparring with
modern growth theories of gold in
economics I'm certainly sparring with
wealth and sparking everybody that's why
I have no friends expiring with the left
I'm sparring at the right the the
essential point I'm making is that what
happened in 1800 their bouts was that
people could have a go as the English
say masses of people ordinary people now
come on there were slaves in the United
States and they were hopelessly poor
people in Britain and so forth so it
wasn't really everybody and all through
this period women were not fully
emancipated but still it was a great
improvement over what it's been a
hundred years before in the way of
allowing people to do stuff to start a
hairdressing salon when they want to and
where to you know is against making them
get a lot license to braid hair which we
don't know and of course these were
inventions not just of a mechanical sort
but of an institutional sort and
inventing stock exchanges and and the
modern university didn't dating from
1810 the University of Berlin so there's
this tremendous upswell coming from
ideas whereas my colleagues most of them
there's a little tiny group that
includes this fellow Joel milk here who
believed that ideas are important but
most of my colleagues in economic
history and economics believe that it's
trade or that it's if they're on the
Left it's slavery or or whatever and the
trouble with that is that we've had
trade and slavery since Cain and Abel
we've had a look in 1792 if you're going
to bet on who is going to have a great
enrichment of 3,000 percent per capita
when previous increases
had been 100% and then falling back to
two or three dollars a day per person
3000 percent per capita in 1492 you
would have been crazy not to bet on
China because China had the most
advanced commercial institutions the
most advanced shipbuilding technology
the most advanced machinery all together
indeed the most advanced science at that
stage so this my claim is that Liberty
was the key so and to put it in a
context of somebody coming out of
literary studies I when I looked at your
work
it's your aunt Ida terminus I am and
there are a lot of libertarians or
free-market people who will say well
it's because the West was well situated
demographically or geographically or we
had natural resources and things at
ports so how do you you know and you're
saying it's essentially ideas and what
are the essential ideas that allowed
people to have a go of it well the
essential idea is as the Blessed Adam
Smith said the liberal plan of equality
liberty and justice by which he meant
social equality he was in a gala terian
somewhat advanced egalitarian for his
age by Liberty he meant this right to
open a hairdressing salon and the like
or to invent a a uber which would
destroy the taxi industry and that that
just in spirits he's getting spirited
people I think it's very important to
not think in mechanical terms I think
socialists and some people some
conservatives think the economy is just
mechanical people are always talking
about I don't know
increasing economic growth in Youngstown
by pouring money into it and that'll
have multiplier effects that is kind of
vaguely Keynesian idea that that you can
make things happen in this mechanical
way but just stuffing
they speak of priming the pump pump and
all that but it's inventing the pump
that's so how did how did it happen that
West creates a system where a lot of
people are relatively equal and can can
act and live how they want and that even
say you know business people are rich
people wealthy people powerful people
will sign on to a system that allows
other people to possibly compete with
them and beat them with that big one if
you're a betting you would never in the
fifteenth century have been on Europe
that would have been stupid this
quarrelsome poor disease-ridden places
fanatics who then became more fanatical
in the 16th century no it was accidents
for example the Protestant Reformation
which Max Weber claimed changed the
psychology of the entrepreneur I don't
think it did I think what it did the
radical Protestant Reformation the
Quakers being the most extreme case one
can think of but also the the
anabaptists and so forth got along
without hierarchies in the in the case
of the the Quakers there's no minister
they just gather in a circle and wait
until the Spirit of the Lord descends
and that experiment in getting away from
what had been the hierarchy in this very
important part of their life namely
religion made people think oh yeah maybe
I could get along without what was what
was the role of chopping up the head of
the Charles the first and all of that
well let's see these are all these are
all contingent no they're all accidents
there's nothing deterministic about them
had Charles been a more sensible man his
father was called the James the first
was called the wise the wisest fool and
christened them but his son wasn't that
much smarter and he said on the scaffold
he was allowed under English law to give
it because he'd been convicted under
English law shocked the whole of Europe
that an anointed prince could be tried I
mean princess died violently all the
time but could be tried and found guilty
he was he said
you understand a sovereign and a subject
are clean different things that's what
broke down this conviction that that's
true
a conviction actually which was
invigorating in II in Europe in the
sixteenth especially the 17th century
all across Europe east and west the
Divine Right of Kings was being asserted
and it could have gone the other way
wrong it could have been that we became
Russia or Prussia for that matter but we
didn't
we became French or British now you you
know you're talking you've made a
allusion to uber and the kind of
regulatory burden that companies or new
businesses new ideas face in 21st
century America hair-braiding of
occupational licensing are we
backsliding from that tradition and what
do we do to arrest that's one of the
reasons I wrote the books he's not about
hair braiding I mean I think it's stupid
and it's bad for poor people weight hair
braiding or operating is bad for poor
boobers is good for parking no I don't
mean hair braiding is yeah the license
yes okay that's likewise making
strategies the litem saying of this the
other thing by the way we economists
don't have any licenses either new
journalists so hey we're lucky I mean
this is the u.s. is about one of the few
countries that doesn't actually never
license the press so we're lucky a are
they licensed in France they were in
different ways and even in Melton's
areopagitica he was for an unlicensed
press or there's a protestant press not
I don't accident that's right exactly of
course him well actually one of the
shocking things about English history
is it until 1967 I think it was or 68
the the theater in London was subject
run to pre-production run oh licensing
if they didn't like what you were saying
you weren't allowed to came in with in
the 1730's under Walpole but who are
these people who vote for Trump or who
votes
or Bernie or for Corbin in Britain who
are they well there's lots of old people
who are angry about the world changing
at all but there are also a lot of young
people especially on the left and the
problem is that young people if they
don't grow up on a farm or a small small
business where they're involved in trade
all the time where they learn what
prices mean where they learn that that
the the daddy's income depends on doing
a good job and then mom is a central
planner of the fan in the in the in the
bourgeois household mom is the central
planner it's a little socialist society
and the income folds like manna from
heaven and so these kids think well
there are poor people let's fix that by
bringing them to the table and from each
according to his need and that makes
perfect sense
I admired very much I practice it myself
in a family but it makes no sense at all
and what Hayek all the great society
before Johnson did and on 324 million
people can't be run like a family
however much Elizabeth Warren would like
it one of the books that is out now that
is causing a big Rao particularly among
libertarians as democracy and chains by
Nancy McLain a historian at Duke
University it's a an attack on James
Buchanan and kind of libertarian
technology I haven't did you did you
have much interaction with James
Buchanan during the course yeah
especially as Deirdre played in my life
I got to know Jim a little bit
he was very courtly about my change of
gender what does that mean well he would
open doors for me it was very nice and
this this idea that Jim is that the dark
side of the force is just crazy
Charles Koch for example is viewed as
the dark money and all that and for some
reason people on the Left where
billionaires can get off but Charles
Koch is a libertarian it believes in
freedom not just his friend Zack teasing
not just making him better off he's
against corporate welfare he's against
this DCG he gives money to the United
Negro College Fund the same is true of
Jimmy as an advocate of freedom so it's
just more of this well look you know as
well as I but on the left there's a
belief about people like you and me but
in its it's psychologically very
implausible but this is what they
believe that you and I want to help the
rich and we disdain the poor and we're
superior to them we they think and this
is all about about us helping rich
people get more rich what kind of human
psychology would lead you to do that I
got into economics I stayed in it to
help the poor the advantage that our
policies have is that they actually help
the poor as against making people feel
good about helping the poor will I have
their their their their their second
cappuccino you have talked about various
forms of libertarianism yeah what is
what is your what's your favorite form
and what has to happen to kind of fully
operation is you may libertarianism so
it's capitalism with a human face it's
all I don't like the word kappapride i
think it's misleading it suggests that
piling up capital is what the modern
world is about and it's not it's about
ideas it's about novelties
I call it sisterly libertarianism I was
at a conference in Yucatan with 500
libertarian
I've never been in a conference with 500
libertarians I was talking to this guy
and I said by way of an axiom that
everyone of course would agree with of
course we all want to help the poor and
he immediately shot back only if they
help me it's good kind of ein Rand tough
guy
screw you I've got mine libertarianism I
call it brotherly - sisterly or motherly
you know the father said the libertarian
father says to the the son is still
living at home at 28 George for Christ's
sakes get a job and his mother says oh
but he's such a nice boy and she offers
us some soup I'ma be offering soup
version can that live does I have to
live with the father though - because
otherwise you just have a kid eating
soup a 30 day both I have a friend as
was the founding editor manager of the
Amsterdam University Press and when she
first started she thought I'm going to
run this enterprise as a woman I'm a
woman and I think that's reasonable
we're going to not have this guy stuff
all the time and she found that worked
to some degree but people didn't meet
their deadlines so she said whoops oh so
she had to bring in some of the fatherly
oh for Christ's sakes get a job over
chrissakes George meet your deadline and
when she mixed the two when there was
enough of love and enough of justice and
prudence mixed in that that works so did
you see sisterly libertarianism or
motherly libertarianism as a corrective
- you know as a self-conscious movement
of you know 40 or 50 years
libertarianism has definitely been very
stereotypically male it's been very male
and as as a former male I understand the
attractions but but I I it doesn't work
politically for one thing we ought to be
saying it everything we write I should
say it right now I
like I have said it in everything we say
we're in favor of helping the poor
because I know I am I know you I know
you are
most of the libertarians I know the
Donna boy and Don Boudreau and all of us
want to help the poor and our techniques
actually do help the poor whereas the
technique of constantly intervening
intervening in the in the wage bargain
has done nothing but hurt the poor it's
made the poor hard to have been blind I
come from Chicago right that's where I
live and the south and west sides
especially the west sides are really
terrible and a nineteenth-century such
places were hives of activity because
there was no zoning there were no no no
building codes there were no no unions
to speak of there was no minimum wage
there was no this and there was no
regulation of wage bargain and you could
get a job you came from Slovakia you
went right into the into the factories
but the the west side of Chicago should
be a hive of industrial activity and
it's not let's talk about trans issues
you mentioned being a man yeah you know
in your brilliant memoir crossing
whichever Luther came in 99
yes i right yeah you discuss your
experience experience with gender
reassignment surgery and a host of
related issues actually the surgery in
many ways is the least of it although
it's all fascinating what do you think
about the ways in which kind of
questions of sexual identity of personal
identity of gender how have they played
out since the publication crossing is it
is it better is of worse because of
anything I've said or done but because
of the general liberal drift of the
society in matters of personal say
sexual choice or gender choice or lots
of other choices and
after all we're starting at last to
legalize marijuana and my my my view is
that that the right to to present in in
whatever gender you want or no gender at
all
is just a species of freedom that we've
been with great waves back and forth but
gradually improving since the 18th
century we freed slaves we freed women
we freed gays we freed colonial people
we freed people of color we freed
handicapped people we freed you know I
had by the way I had opinions on all of
these I was in fact on the right side
every time I was a liberal but I didn't
do anything about it
and then in 1995 got tapped me and my
episcopal god tapped me on the shoulder
and said okay dear this is your last
chance so I you know I I was public
about it it's a little hard to change
gender in private anyway so it I
regarded it as a he actually did I
didn't immediately so I realized that it
was an expression of my libertarianism
as well are you optimistic about you
know the next 50 years is and I guess
another way of saying that is Donald
Trump is lepen is Corbin or whatever are
they the end of something or are they
the beginning of a kind of new chapter
of awfulness I think they're the end I'm
an optimist you don't change Jenner
unless you're an optimist but we got to
be on our guard we've got to do things
like eff conversations like this and get
people to listen to them because it's a
danger young people as I said of this
tendency to socialism old people have
this tendency to fascism so if you put
the duty
gather you nationalism socialism
national socialism and it's happened
before
it's very dangerous it's always present
so we need to work against it I'm about
I'm going to go to Hungary for a few few
days in a couple of months and I'm so
sad about Hungary and then : seems to be
going the same way that they Glory the
co2 the the politicians in in in Hungary
glory in being a liberal they say it
they say we're going to do a liberal
democracy by which they mean fixed
elections well we will leave it there
Thank You Deirdre so much for talking
thank you very much enjoy we have been
talking with Deirdre McCloskey she's in
a Merida professor of economics history
English and communication I'm
disappointed that you're not in a suburb
or Department I am how is enhancement in
philosophy and classics art history
maybe textiles really thought yes at the
University of Illinois at Chicago choose
the author most recently Bush why
equality how ideas not capital or
institutions enrich the world
it's also a recent columnist again
thanks thank you here for a reason I'm
Nick Gillespie
[Music]
you